if you were able to let's say
make the same money
and race dirt cars would you do it
um
i don't know i i think
i think maybe
if you'd asked me that question seven or
eight years ago i probably would say
yeah
but i think as i've gotten older um i
just enjoy race in all types of cars so
it doesn't matter to me
if it's dirt pavement stock car sprint
car late model
you know indycar someday who cares like
it doesn't matter to me i just want to i
love i love driving race cars more than
i love making money so
um it doesn't
it doesn't uh it doesn't
i don't know it doesn't it doesn't
matter to me maybe like it it would have
and maybe i had you know eight years ago
or more you know a chip on my shoulder
where like i'm gonna you know
lean more towards the dirt stuff just to
have their back and stuff but
now like it doesn't matter to me it's
kind of like a cult
yes i mean
i don't know it's gotten it's gotten
less of that way i feel like over the
last few years um because i feel like
there's more transition now because
you've got other drivers besides myself
doing it all
or not all but you know dabbling at
chase is dabbling in the in the dirt
stuff kyle busch with his son braxton um
and then yokai ran the shootout last
week so i feel like there's a lot more
of the crossover and i feel like fans
kind of appreciate all racing
as a whole more than maybe they did a
few years ago
i think probably my biggest criticism on
dirt racing again because we're such
good friends and obviously we've talked
about this many times is the danger
aspect you know seeing people you like
people that we know like i know a lot
less people in dirt racing than you do
but like i knew guys that died regular
you know people were passing
all old time and it's um
you know it always just seems like you
know i get it if you're if it's your
livelihood but
um when you have a livelihood that is
really good then it's kind of like dude
these guys would give up
they they give up their job for your job
um so
does that even play into it or is that
part of the allure
i don't think it's part of the allure at
all but um
i don't know i i don't think about it at
all when i strap into a dirt car i'm not
thinking about this could be my last
race i ever run in my life or
what you know i just love i think my
passion for racing and passion for dirt
racing
um
keeps me coming back and like i said i
it doesn't it's not about the money to
me
um
but i do know there's a lot of people
that rely on me driving say a nascar you
know cup car there's hundreds of
employees at hendrick there's hundreds
of employees that i was at ganassi that
rely on me so i understand that side of
it but
i i do think the
positives of you know what could come
from you benefiting as a race car driver
could you know outweigh you the risk
side of it but yes there's always a risk
um and i think
anybody could have their own opinion on
that so
for me i feel like it really benefits my
racing and i and i think it's i've been
able to prove it now the last couple
years knock on wood nothing you know bad
has
happened but uh
yes i think we all understand that the
risk is there and it's kind of part of
it but uh that's just because you blow
by you blow by everybody so i don't know
when you were around though it was that
was like a bad that was a bad few years
um you know with tony getting hurt brian
clawson lefler
so many other not so many other drivers
yes jason johnson i mean and even people
not losing their lives you know breaking
their backs and stuff like that so
um
yes it's dangerous but there's danger in
all everything we do every day you know
even your crossfit can be dangerous
danica i don't do crossfit anymore then
i still have a barbell in my garage but
i don't do crossfit anymore
um i i mean it's a fact i just i'm just
so curious about it you know so what is
it then that what is like what's the
sensation if you could uh express sort
of
try and paint that picture for people
they see stock car racing but maybe
people don't know as much about dirt
racing and stock cars obviously on
pavement mostly ovals
like you know
there's a lot going on that you don't
really see um in a race car so
um you know
but it people can visualize a stock car
going around a track what are you
feeling like dirt dirt
dirt racing like sideways explain it to
people and then what's the sensation
that's different than a stock car
well i guess i'll start by like
comparing the two cars um
you know a stock car is well up until
this year was 550 horsepower 3400 pound
race car a sprint car wing sprint car is
1400 pounds with 950 to a thousand
horsepower these days so
um
it's the power to weight ratio is is
um you know pulls the front tires off
the ground you know lights the top rear
tires up on the throttle so there's so
much finesse and
uh the style of racing is is aggressive
because the races are short you know
main event might only be 30 laps
compared to four or 500 mile races so
um the intensity is is really high um
and yeah it's just the track conditions
are changing lap by lap uh because you
know it's on dirt so it's you're
constantly drying out or getting ruts or
building a cushion and
the awareness that you have to have as a
driver is is uh something that i think
is a good tool for when i go to the
nascar side of things where you have
more time to get you know
figure things out um you know adjusting
to a line and stuff like that um the
spread car stuff is more intense but you
know the pavement stuff i think is also
a good tool because it teaches you the
patience um you know the precision of
hitting your marks that i think really
helps when i get back to the dirt stuff
especially when it comes to like having
to slow down and run the bottom so
um
i don't know just the the
they're hard to compare
there is really not much comparison but
uh they're both really fun
what's the sensation that you love do
you love being sideways do you love
like
running by the wall every night pretty
well not every night but i'm sure last
night
uh i don't know i think i think the
sensation even though the tracks too the
tracks and dirt are way smaller you know
you're racing on a quarter mile to a
half mile where the smallest track in
nascar is a half mile so
um
uh you know it's uh
just that speed that you feel on a
quarter mile could feel faster than what
michigan on a two mile track would feel
like even though you're going
almost half the speed uh sometimes so
just because the quickness and the
reaction that it takes to in the
suspension you know a stock car like
it's pretty rigid it doesn't move a
whole lot you know if you hit a bump it
doesn't move a ton where a sprint car i
mean your your car will travel inches um
in bouncing and flipping and wrecking
and all that so uh but i would say the
sensation of the speed and
my heart rate gets way higher uh in a
dirt race than than it would in a stock
car it's just because i think in the
stock cars you have such a long you're
straight away to kind of relax and
things get spread out so
yeah it's uh the sensation of
reaction and speed is wild
people which i would i feel like would
maybe be similar to like an indy car i
would have to imagine you know because
they're quick and twitchy and edgy oh
yeah this is the i mean i mean when i
jumped back in an indy car a couple
years ago for the last time um i mean i
took off out of pit lane and first
thought was like oh [ __ ] i forgot how
fast these are like i accelerated off of
pit lane on the back straightaway at
indianapolis and i was like oh god and
then i was like i can't even turn the
wheel i was like this is so hard yeah um
i mean there's a lot about an indy car
that i think is probably similar to a
dirt car did your cars have power
steering
yes yeah they have power steering which
is thankfully they do but it still gets
you can get heavy
a heavy wheel when you're bouncing
through holes and stuff like it'll it'll
try and yank itself out of your hands
the dirt late model
those cars are similar horsepower to a
sprint car but they weigh i think a
thousand pounds more
and there's so much load on the front
tires in those things just the way the
suspension is
on the right front it makes the steering
really heavy in those so yeah i've have
it where not i have had it where like i
go through a hole and it'll literally
yank out of my hands and i take off up
the track so
um definitely takes more arm strength in
the late model um
but still again the sprint car compared
to that like your heart rate is way
higher in the sprint car compared to
late model
did you win chili bowl last year
yeah the last two years i've won for
those listening that um might not know
as much detail
about you
um
your season in 2021 was just ridiculous
i mean
you won 11 cup races 10 regular season
and the all-star race which pays a
million bucks right isn't it a million
bucks to win the all-star race
um
you got to try and compete with caitlyn
for those t-shirt sales money so it's
good that you won that
um and then i don't know all the dirt
races but obviously won the chili bowl
and i know you want a whole bunch of
others which for people that don't know
like
these are the biggest dirt races these
are like the these are the super bowl
these are the world series this is the
daytona 500 of of dirt racing and it
almost feels like there's more energy
and excitement around it than even a cup
race on some level like you can you you
would probably agree
um so which one which dirt races did you
win that were the big ones yeah last
year i was able to run
i ran what a [ __ ] a sprint car dirt
late model and a cup car
and i won marquee events on all four
types of cars so yeah i started out with
the chili bowl at uh
in tulsa in the [ __ ] so the two big
races i won the [ __ ] with the chili
bowl and the bc39 that's in the infield
at ims
uh in the sprint car i won the kings
royal and the knoxville nationals those
are the two biggest sprint car races of
the year
in the dirt late model i won
uh the prairie dirt classic which is i
would say probably like the fourth
biggest race in dirt late models and
then
i mean the coke 600 the all-star race
phoenix
there was there was a lot a lot of good
good big ones uh in cup as well so
that's definitely something i'm really
proud about um i think i ran 96 or seven
races
uh last year and won 33 of them